meet the actual SEMO it may seem like a
phone holder of sorts but this is a HDMI
to USB monitoring adapter it essentially
gives your iPhone or iPad a HDMI port
allowing you to turn it into a
full-fledged monitoring device with all
the bells and whistles of a dedicated
monitor that includes recording
streaming and even sharing your images
and videos on the fly but some might say
why do you need a monitor if your camera
already has an inbuilt display well if
you ever had a rig that was built in a
way where the screen is blocked or if
you have a camera without a full
articulating screen or perhaps you need
more screen real estate to capture finer
details such as pulling Focus chances
are you might be considering getting a
field monitor though some might say it's
such a hassle to carry additional gear
and not to mention the added cost to
your presumably expensive setup so why
not take the advantage of your already
existing gadgets and gizmos priced at
179 US Dollars it is one of the most
affordable monitors out there money can
buy well all except for the separate
purchase of an iPhone of course so if
you're in a pinch and you have a spare
iPhone on hand this too a great addition
to your camera rig and I'm very
surprised to find that there are no
similar devices out there in the market
for iOS devices so without further Ado
let's hop in but before that let's take
a quick minute to talk about today's
sponsor Asus this video is brought to
you by Asus check out the Asus Zenbook
14x OLED Space Edition commemorating the
25th anniversary of the first Asus
laptop sent into space Not only does it
offer a space exclusive design but it's
even worthy of going where no man has
gone before with its space grade
durability it even comes with a 3.5 inch
OLED companion Zen Vision display and
you will have a ball of a time taking
interviews with a 16x10 4K OLED Nano
Edge Pantone validated 14-inch display
now included in the box is the main unit
a cold shoe mount
cables a USBC to lightning for the
iPhone and a USBC to USBC to your iPad
which makes it a very useful and
practical monitor that some of you
running gun shooters will enjoy now the
main unit has a HDMI port to connect
your iPhone or iPad and a USBC 5 volt
out for charging certain mirrorless
hybrid cameras via the npf battery
housed at the back now there's also a
coat mount on top of this adapter for
additional accessories like a microphone
or a light now the build quality is what
you expect really Hardy plastic and the
overall design is fairly simple and
straightforward now there are a few
things I really like about the design
and we'll get to that later but other
than that what's not included is that
you have to get yourself a couple of mpf
series rechargeable lithium ion battery
packs now they come in a variety of
sizes but we do recommend that you stick
with a lower capacity for you running
gun shooters out there are trying to
keep their camera rigs light now of
course by all means you can stick an 8
000 milliamp hour battery like we did
which will perpetually keep the adapter
powered up pretty much the whole day of
shooting and that comes to my first
drawback of the xoc mode see you have a
big battery charging the adapter but why
can't it also charge the phone I
I just look at it anyway what's cool
here is that action has also given the
option of mounting up your iPad but
essentially the back comes off like so
and this is where you will Mount the
iPad which you sold separately of course
I found out the hardware and I almost
thought I broke the whole thing so no
harm no file here just you know just
don't go overboard now for those who are
wondering if there are iOS devices is
supported it is compatible with the
iPhone 8 and above with a small
disclaimer here that if you are using an
iPhone 12 or 13 mini you will need a
separate case to clamp it on securely
with the adapter now with that sit here
is the list of compatible devices for
the accent zimo just note this down yeah
now using it is pretty simple just plug
in the battery and the HDMI cable clamp
in your phone via the spring loading
locking mechanism Allah the action Simo
emblem over there and just push in and
there you go it clamps on just like that
now you load up the axun CF which is
available on the App Store on your phone
and Bam A Whole New World of monitoring
tools or weights you have officially
unlocked focus peaking waveforms
histogram Force color anamorphic D
squeeze frame lines and so much more so
let's dive into the app and see what we
have here now for what it's worth the
app is very well organized and well laid
out with access to almost everything you
need some consider these essential tools
and for some maybe a little bit overkill
for the uninitiated but hey you've got
professional grade tools here for all
your filmmaking needs another cool
feature here is that you can pinch to
zoom in so if you like to double check
your focus you can actually do that now
for the more advanced you have the
option to shoot in log and also have
monitoring light presets now there are a
few presets that you can choose from and
all you need to do is go into this
option called looks and you can actually
find a whole slew of like pre-loaded
Luts in this app unfortunately you can't
add your own nuts but you do already
have some log files already catered to
specific camera manufacturers so you can
get Canon loc C reloxy red log GoPro
tune Fujifilm f-log Sony s-lock and so
much more so excellent has covered as
much as they could for even professional
Shooters who want to grade their own
footage down the line now that is pretty
nifty especially if you work in Lock and
you need some gamma display assist to
get your exposures right but for the
most part I leave my setting in default
and work on color grade in post again I
see this more as a monitoring device and
not a recorder for scope of work here
and it is also important to note that if
you are recording natively on your phone
your output is limited to full HD 1080
at either 30 frames or 60 frames per
second with 8-bit color and a maximum
bit rate of 30 megabytes per second now
the downside here is you can't output
raw footage from the camera but that
makes sense due to the hardware
limitations and you're better off
investing in an atomore shotgun to
really tap into the full capabilities of
the camera but hey maybe axun can look
into it and see if that's even possible
who knows I love the fact that I can
have audio waveforms that I can monitor
and better yet you can actually monitor
audio tool using your airports or
wireless earbuds now you do get a little
bit of latency with wireless audio here
but it is manageable and I'm sure it
will work out fine for you now the
recording feature of the actual Simo
only makes sense if you're editing a
project on the fly to social media sites
like YouTube shots or Facebook wheels or
Instagram and Tick Tock I've experienced
very low latency maybe a couple of
frames shy but it is ready to be used on
the field now the features work well and
I can dial up the intensity of the focus
speaking just to make sure my subject is
in focus and the frame lines help guide
my shots whether I'm shooting for white
screen or even vertical format on top of
the recording capabilities you're also
able to run a live feed from your camera
using your phone's Wi-Fi or Data Network
to do live streams granted it is not as
straight forward as other apps and it
will require you to enter a stream key
or an rtmp server link to get it up and
running now for those who have no idea
what I just said you also know would
know and that's the issue right I hope
action will update the app to make it
easier and more streamlined where you
can just enter your Twitch credentials
or your YouTube credentials and the such
again this is where I feel act soon has
done something cool here but it's
lacking the final touches to really
bring its full functionality home so I
hope act soon brings about a more
user-friendly UI and the Integrations in
the next iteration of the Excellency app
now from a Creator's perspective this
has definitely made shooting video a lot
easier it's cheap and easy to set up and
it makes monitoring more accessible now
like how I got it set up with the Nikon
z62 it's a great camera but the downside
is that there's no fully articulating
screen so I can't flip the screen to
really mirror the shots and check on my
focus so the accent symbol will also be
perfect for you vloggers out there let
me know honestly it's gonna be really
handy for all types of situations if
you're just starting out to make content
on your own or if you're from a
production house that needs a backup
monitor in case something happens or if
you need more screen real estate to view
your shot this actually works well and
how I see the onboard recording function
as of right now is a neat little way of
having proxy footage or backup footage
where you can record it and drop it to
the editor's iPad the editors can edit
that right off the bat while the shoot
is still simultaneously happening again
30 megabytes per second is well
reasonably decent for a HD recording
through an app on a phone and I find
that it's more than good enough for
social media use on top of that here's a
fun fact that you can do with the Simo 2
you can play games on your switch or PS5
and record your gameplay sessions
turning your phone into a pseudo capture
card Food For Thought yeah
leave it sir Linda go with that being
said the excellent Seymour is not
perfect and here are some of the
drawbacks I've experienced using it
starting off with the fact that it does
not charge your phone I'm sure it's a
hardware limitation but if you're out on
a six hour shoot and you're not going to
get very far with your iPhone's display
on full brightness with apps still
running in the background so on and so
forth and yes I know that's pretty much
the whole point of this device to keep
the battery solely for the CMO and yes
you can slap on a power bank somewhere
on your rig for the iPhone alone but hey
in moments where you have none in reach
it'd be nice touch to have that option
somehow now with that said I would have
preferred to have seen an inbu battery
and or a USB C power input added as well
with such a small size lightweight
adapter you know it doesn't make a lot
of sense for users to have to power that
battery that weighs substantially more
than the device itself as the CMO only
draws about 2 Watts or a maximum of four
to five Watts if you are using it with
of an iPad now having the ability to
power it via battery or through an
internal battery or even an external USB
Source will make it a lot more versatile
well at least in my opinion now the
other problem here is the power button
really should have been a slider because
the only way to tell that the device is
on is with this LED light and you also
got a battery level indicator here now
the LEDs are pretty faint and they don't
stand out to be noticeable on the field
now the other thing is the Tilt you got
to use an allen key to adjust it and the
build quality on it is you know mostly
plastic so you may want to rethink
putting anything heavy into this cold
show Mount up top in this case it breaks
now what action could have done here was
maybe to provide a more premium version
that could address these issues and you
know what I would definitely get that
and I would definitely pay it more at
this price point the actual CMO is a
great alternative to Dedicated monitors
that offer both monitoring and recording
capabilities that will be great for for
Content creators and professionals and I
really believe excellent has definitely
created a new product type in the market
and I just hope with future iterations
be it from act soon or any other company
that they address the issues that come
with this first iteration so that's it
comment below and I'll do my best to get
to them follow us on all of our socials
right here and if you like this video
make sure to hit that like And subscribe
button because it goes a long way and if
you want to see more of our content
check this out
[Music]
thank you